[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
major witnesses called in the derek
shovin trial the teen who filmed the now
viral video describes seeing george
floyd die
a man terrified and scared begging for
his life plus an mma fighter tears up
while listening to the 9-1-1 call he
placed that day
and the heated exchange between defense
attorney and witness about his actions
did you say that is that what you heard
i'm asking you sir
did you say that you heard that i'm
pretty sure you did
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome to long crime daily i'm dan
abrams filling in for brian buckmeyer
who is in minneapolis for the trial of
derek chovin and with us as always is
terry austin brian some more big
testimony from the prosecution what do
they have
we're going to call this witness by her
first name only because she just turned
18. darnella a minor who was 17 at the
time she took out her phone to film an
officer with his knee on the neck of a
black man on the street she was
emotional as she described the events on
may 25th 2020. she asked not to have her
face shown and the judge ruled not for
it to be seen because she was a minor at
the time
what did you do when you first got there
and we see where you're standing what
did you do
i pulled out my phone
and what were you doing and pulling out
your phone
recording capturing what i was seeing
i heard george floyd saying
i can't breathe please
get off of me i can't breathe he he
cried for his mom
he was in pain
it seemed like
he knew
it seemed like he knew it was over for
him
he was terrified
he was suffering this was a cry for help
before we talk more about what happened
in court on day two take us back and
remind us where we are in this case
brian
dad prosecutors say derek chauvin killed
george floyd by kneeling on his neck
last year but while chauvin's lawyer
says floyd died from the drug use and a
combination of heart problems leading to
his death
derek showman is facing three charges
second degree murder second degree
manslaughter and third degree murder he
faces up to 40 years in prison if
convicted
fourteen people make up the jury twelve
members plus two alternates will hear
the case eight of those identify as
white four as black and two as
multiracial during opening statements
prosecutors said chauvin kneeled on
floyd's neck for nine minutes and 29
seconds find mr chavin guilty
for his excessive use of force against
joyce floyd that was an assault
that contributed taking this light
and for engaging in imminently dangerous
behavior putting the knee on the neck
the knee on the back for nine minutes
and 29 seconds without regard for mr
floyd's life shop's defense says floyd
ingested pills containing fentanyl they
argue that the drugs combined with a
heart condition are what led to floyd's
death the evidence will show
that mr floyd died of a cardiac
arrhythmia
that occurred as a result of
hypertension his coronary disease
the ingestion of methamphetamine and
fentanyl and the adrenaline throwing
flowing through his body
all of which acted to further
compromise an already compromised heart
all right brian you are there at the
courthouse what has been the initial
response outside to the first couple of
days of testimony in this trial
yeah dan yesterday there was a much more
of a crowd right where i was right where
i'm standing now actually at the
beginning of opening statements
yesterday
george floyd's family was here to take a
knee with reverend al sharpton as well
as attorney benjamin crump for that
eight minutes and 46 seconds a symbolic
but also powerful display of how long
they believe derek shoving was on george
floyd's neck
we also saw protests after the court you
could hear them even before i'm standing
here just up the block but today a much
quieter scene as testimony is rolling
out in the court
so as brian mentioned prosecutors called
a key witness the then 17 year old who
filmed the incident on her cell phone
that was seen around the world here's
more of what she said but this time on
cross-examination by the defense
remember she was a minor at the time
and her face is not going to be shown
you weren't saying much if anything to
the officers right
i don't remember
but as time went on and more people
showed up
voices became louder would you agree
with that
as we understood more of what was
happening
you ultimately
ended up posting your video to social
media right
correct
and it went viral
and
was that a surprise to you
definitely
changed your life right
the odd objective is beyond the scope
overall
yes it changed your life yes
now on redirect the prosecutors asked
darnella how viewing what happened to
george floyd has impacted her life
when i look at
george floyd i look at
i look at my dad i look at
my brothers i look at my cousins my
uncles
because they are all black
and i i look at that and i look at how
that could have been one of them
it's been nice
i stayed up
apologizing and
and
apologizing
to george floyd for not doing more
and
not
physically interacting
and
not saving his life but it's like
it's not what i should have done
it's what he should have done
powerful stuff there brian i want to
come back to the cross examination for a
moment it does seem that the defense is
really digging in on this notion that
somehow
derek chovin may have been distracted by
all the yelling and the voices around
him at that scene
exactly dan what the defense is really
arguing is saying that it's a crowd i
know there's a bit of a discrepancy i
haven't heard much from the prosecution
trying to color in a different way but
these witnesses are who are taking the
stand they're part of that distraction
the defense is blaming uh partly on why
um george floyd died i'm not sure how
well that's going to be played out for
the jury but it's definitely a part of
his defense and terry austin i've said
that i think that that's a dangerous
argument for them to make what do you
make of it it's a very dangerous
argument there's no question that the
crowd had nothing to do with the death
of george floyd they were simply doing
the opposite trying to save his life
they were saying get off of his neck
they were trying to get a pulse so the
fact that they're trying to blame the
crowd now is ironic and i think it's
going to hurt them because the witnesses
have all testified including darnella
she testified that they weren't rowdy
they weren't unruly they weren't in any
way shape or form threatening any of the
officers they were simply trying at the
time to save the life of george floyd
but even if they were the problem is is
that the legal defense that oh yeah yeah
i forgot i forgot to take my knee uh off
of his neck because i was distracted it
just seems to me that that's it again
even as a strictly legal matter
dangerous territory all right we're
going to come back to both of you still
ahead on law and crime daily a child
takes the stand in the case against
derek joe mixed martial arts expert and
witness nearly brought to tears as he
testified about the nine-on-one one call
he had made about derrick chauvin
antoinette levy is at the courthouse and
has much more on what donald williams
told the jury about a particular type of
chokehold angenette yeah that's right
dan and donald williams says he actually
started wrestling back in junior high
school and has worked a number of
private security jobs over the years he
told the jury what he saw that night
last may and even sparred a little bit
with the defense
you can see that he's trying to you know
gasp for air you know and trying to um
be able to breathe as he's down there
donald williams testified he went to cup
foods last may 25th to get something to
drink but stopped when he saw people
standing near a police cruiser as i was
sitting here i just was really
trying to keep my professionalism-ness
and make sure that i speak out for
floyd's
life because i felt like he was in very
much danger williams said he didn't feel
he could intervene when he saw derrick
chauvin kneeling on george floyd's neck
he's not responsive right now bro but he
did yell at the officers telling them
they were killing floyd williams told
the jury he believed chauvin was using a
blood choke hold with a shimmy what's
the purpose of doing a shimmy to close
the gap of the air between your arm and
the
neck he just did it right there
you'll see his foot is under his toe is
pointed down
and you will see a small adjuster in his
back foot like this
and that's just the pressure you push
more down between
his knee george head and the concrete
and cut off circulation on
cross-examination eric nelson questioned
williams about his credentials have you
ever officially been asked to
train police officers specifically in
the use of chocolate and he questioned
williams about his behavior in that
statement you said like i really wanted
to beat out of the police officers
you said that
yeah i did that's what i thought you
called him a bum at least 13 times
that's what you counted in the video
that's what i counted
and that's she got 13.
and that line of questioning was really
designed by eric nelson to paint this
picture that there was this crowd that
was going to become unruly and was
distracting derek chovin and the other
officers and that was taking their
attention away from george floyd the
defense says that chauvin was following
his training with the hold that he used
that night dan
and jeannette thank you um terry austin
how significant do you think it is that
this eyewitness also has this background
as an mma fighter meaning there was
actually legal arguments uh pre-trial
about exactly what he'd be able to
testify to in terms of his background
and experience
well that's right dan and i think the
judge allowed quite a bit of testimony
to come in and he did have some training
obviously in these choke holes and i
thought it was very effective that the
jury got a chance to hear what he
thought about the difference between the
blood choke and the difference between
an air choke and i thought that when
eric nelson was cross-examining him that
he went a little bit too far now maybe
the witness shouldn't have gotten so
upset but i think it was very good that
he stuck to what he was trying to say
about how dangerous it was what children
was doing at that point in time and how
those little movements that shimmy made
a big difference as far as you know the
death of george floyd is concerned
yeah and on redirect the prosecutor
asked williams about whether officer tao
who tried to de-escalate the situation
whether he did and and jeannette what
was his response
yeah he said that officer tau basically
did nothing and almost made the
situation worse by some of the things
that he said tau was quoted as saying
and you can hear it on the body camera
something to the effect of well this is
what this is what drugs do to you this
is what happens when you do drugs so
the officers didn't do anything to
de-escalate the situation in donald
william's mind yeah
all right
thank you everyone stand by coming up on
law and crime daily a closer look at
derek
welcome back one of the most impactful
witnesses on a sort of human level in
the derek shovin trial was also the
youngest now the teen who filmed the
video
brought her nine-year-old cousin with
her to that cup foods where the incident
began and on the witness stand i was sad
and kind of mad
and tell us why were you sad in that
because
it felt like he was stopping his
breathing
and it is kind of like hurting him
it's heartbreaking just to hear a
nine-year-old and brian the defense
decided not to cross-examine her but it
would have been insane to do so right
absolutely when the prosecution puts a
witness like that on the stand a
nine-year-old who has the ability to to
say i thought that this individual was
not having the ability to breathe the
prosecution has to do two things one
check and see if the defense is gonna
cross-examine uh that witness and i
think the defense are smart not to but
also on summation say even a
nine-year-old knew this was wrong i
think it's gonna be powerful on many
levels and terry that's the advantage of
having someone so young on the witness
stand is you can't really challenge
their credibility or their motives it's
just what they saw and what they felt
that's exactly right you know eric
nelson didn't want to appear as though
he was badgering a nine-year-old and he
probably made a calculation that she
didn't have any new information to give
her cousin already testified and she was
just going to be adding to the fact that
she saw the knee on the neck and so i
think it was the right calculation by
the defense and the fact that he
literally just said pass on this witness
was the right move to make
all right um
when we come back
derek shovin before the death
[Music]
welcome back the judge in the chauvin
trial has ruled the jury will hear about
an incident in 2017
when derek shoven ordered a woman who
apparently was not resisting to be quote
hogtied chief investigative
correspondent brian ross spoke to that
woman's attorney who says her case is
not the only one
thanks coming up this week on brian ross
investigates an advanced look at who and
what the jury in the derek shoving trial
may hear about the background and the
record of the accused police officer
this is zoya code one of two witnesses
the prosecution wants to call to testify
about how they were treated in previous
incidents
her lawyer zoroslof lederman says it
grew out of a domestic dispute what can
the zoya code testify to
well mrs code had a similar encounter
with mr chauvin where
he was taking her into custody
and he treated her
in a similar manner that he treated um
mr floyd uh the the issue there is this
um
kneeing over the neck um this is what
the
this is what the prosecution was looking
for in terms of getting her testimony in
um and i also believe that
this is what the judge looked at as well
in determining that her
testimony will be allowed
um is the the specific um the specific
use of force and how it was carried out
and the similarities between her
incident
uh and mr floyd in terms of how officer
chavin used force
and how seriously if at all was she
injured in the encounter
anytime you have a police officer who
is on top of you
you're being restrained
they're applying pressure through your
neck
um anybody who's being arrested is
already under stress
it's not a very pleasant situation to be
in
i prefer not to go into detail just
because she's expected to testify at
trial and i don't want to create
any other issues well similar that we
saw with the settlement i don't want to
have a problem come up in the trial
where
i tell you something that may end up
causing more questions of the jury so i
prefer to leave that as is but if she
does testify she will tell her story and
you'll be able to see what happened
and you expect it to be impactful
i i think about it yes
and what is she like
she's a you know a regular person just
like many other people that are
often abused by the police mr floyd was
not the first person to die at the hands
of minneapolis police and he will not be
the last unfortunately the city has
as we've heard the news has settled his
case with the family which
which i believe is appropriate
but the question is is the is the
culture of abuse within the minneapolis
police department going to stop and i
haven't seen evidence of that you know
given mr floyd's case and given prior
recent cases we have here i don't see
any evidence of the police department
changing substantially in a way that it
treats the public that's coming up this
week on brian ross investigates on the
law and crime trial network
brian ross thank you brian buckmeyer
there was a big legal battle over
whether that testimony could come in
and in the end the judge said that he'd
allow it
absolutely dan we're going to hear that
testimony as well i believe another
testimony from another instance with
derek chovin they the prosecution tried
to get i think nine in total but the
judge ruled that based on the facts only
these two will come in because they're
more similarly situated to the to the
situation that happened with george
floyd terry i think sometimes people
underestimate how significant past acts
testimony can be in a trial like this
well that's right and i'm glad that they
were able to get these prior bad acts in
and the two acts that did come in on the
prosecution's request was this 2017 act
that we're referring to where chovin
again kneeled on someone who wasn't
resisting and they offered it to prove
that children was using unreasonable
force and that he intended to assault
floyd you know the other issue was the
2015 incident where he didn't use deadly
force where he knew and where he
understood what the procedure was and
the judge said that he was letting that
in because it showed that children knew
understand and he wasn't making a
mistake when he applied the force that
he did in that incident so i think the
two incidents that he let in obviously
were within the bounds of the law in
minnesota and the federal rules of you
know 404 and so i think it all worked
out and and remember though that there
will also be some information coming in
about george floyd's past as well um so
the judge really had to sort of balance
this prosecutors wanted a lot of derrick
shovens passed in defense wanted a lot
of george floyd's he let in a little bit
of it on each side all right
terry and brian thank you so much
[Music]